今日も元気で取れまぞうこんにちははじめで夏ぶりに富山県に帰ってきました
あのなんで今回と矢部家に帰ってきたかと言いますとはじめのファンクラブのイベント
で握手会があってきてるんですけども
ついでにれちゃくちゃ久しぶりに弟にあることができました
ちょい中僕の動画に出てると思うんですけどもなんと無事大学卒業できない
でございますおめでとうございますそして鳥に伴い内定が取れて就職も決まったみたい
でもうこれでようやく
社会人としてあとうとうも一歩踏み出すところであると思うんですけどもうこの私が超
渡せねぇちょっと山をさせたいところあるんですけどやっぱり僕は作ら数も弟には別に
ユーチューバーになれとは言わないんですけどまぁ骨と3粒はいいんじゃないかなぜい
るー
思いが多少なりともあるんで最後のチャンスなんですよ大学4年生で仕事に就いたら
なかなかそうもいかないんでも g 1を選ぶ最終チャンスでなんとか生きんどうだっ
た久しぶりって話もまずい
まずは弟ユーチューバーにしてやろうかなと思いました夢なら肇社長の弟のいうだけで
もスタートラインが違いますけどねうーん
新崎でせっかくのチャートを流すわけには行きません音と宇宙ばに沿ってみようと思い
ます来ないか
こういうかも入ってるよどうぞ初めて武蔵上です
何ヶ月ぶりでヶ月じゃないんだ
去年の夏ぶりだぁー1年1年なるほど
1年ぶりでございが変わって
噂に聞いたが
お前
お前刷良牙て欲しいなぁかあるございます
なのは
4目線創造言っていればの一時期を前太陽としてきてやばいとだったらしいなぁ完成し
ての葉
反省してますワケアリでも卒業をくれたのは留学質だからで初動そうそうそうなりゃ
見えて完全に同じパターンですよ半年間留学行ってその分半期いうわけで卒業
久場摂取がつか1年契約とぷっなんでじゃれあっに住んで後シール学官とし u 2
ああああっ
アントスのゆず弾き感で本当にこれでいけんのか行けないのか判別機か想像ゲトったん
で打つちょっと考えならばこっちに来ていますよ私やとりあえずなぜと強く思って本当
にもうこの親に対するメーカー大学二人行かせるってやばいかにょだじゃあこれで
社会人のギター
今後は俺たちで様を家族に関していかなきゃっていう立場だからがんばっていき
ましょう
頑張ります何でカメラに向かってどうだおお前お前林くっ限り
お前を修飾した形状があるらしいな日本語やばけれ
モーゼ聖書が決まったと決まったあおめでとうだよなぁ翼型ね運が良かった
本当に何か言う女シリーズで所止めですが思ったんだけどさー数色各をしてるわけ
じゃん
顔は隠しているものさわかる人にはわかるわけであなたも存在が火事御坂もっととって
就活影響もありました
いや実際特にはあなただったと思う
なんかとでもまぁ就活生のタイミングでエギが苗字をネタにしたのはちょっと待って
[音楽]
ブービー育毛1は日時に行かれる
よるファンくるの後輩と彼にはっきり3町の音たんですね満足なる一人っ子ですねハッ
ハーお前はああ悪いなぁ
で面倒臭いやなぁそうなちょっと結局じゃどこで昼食
関東で語る予定ね東京っていうことを今日でいただきたいと思った
キー坊だなうわぁ夫婦シティーボーイでねくうううっ
東京ならもう本社が東京できたら今社で働きたいというか
お前もついに就職か
一応
最後に聞きたいことがあるんだからお前
[音楽]
ユーチューバーにならねーか
+やはあるはいどーこだよくのためください今なると初めに2つ弟っていうプラントで
スタートダッシュはいいと思うんだよああ
第結構友達の言われ最初はいけるんじゃないのと言いでもパパに木内かけてみてるし
珍島さんを知っとるし外に出れんとかもあるし捨てるもの大きい訳あっておりそれを
天秤にかけたときに
イージーはを違うなーって言うと雰囲気にプライド覆面兄弟関係みたいな
違うかなって思ってしまうから売れを無料フル
ua
me
dare
ああああああ
畑のメンバーは行って
8両ゲームはなんで兄だとやって演習で金人が増えてもしれまといった部分もあるし
やっぱりそのメンバーの中に入れた時に空気が見てあげてパターンてくれであるかどう
かもよくわかっ
あんた真面目だねこんなは知る変えていると勝ってりゃ色々
田上ニールつはならないという意味ですん
タイプと言えるわけですね俺からすると最終段階があります
大学生が終わってしまう決まってるからあなたはユーチューバー引きずり込むやいます
かないと思う
最後にもう一度行こう
youtube にありますかん
分
うん
なりません珍しん
me
うううう
me あった